it wasn't even as a grain of sand in my
brain that people wouldn't want to help
starving drowning families I think it's
a concern about Islamic terrorists that
sneak into the refugee camps so that
they can perform their jihad in America
I don't care if it's just one if you
bring a hundred people in here and it's
only two of them as to two-minute it's
unnecessary we have enough problems in
this country Montana has always had its
buckets of white fear you know I mean if
you look across Montana Wyoming and
parts of Idaho we are very much a white
only society here these are the last
areas of of white countryside you know
and I think they want to keep it that
way